from chips or crisps to fries and potato
pancakes many cultures have perfected
recipes for the fried potato but what if
it was your entire food supply what if
you only ate chips the most popular
brand of chips worldwide is Lay's
classic this 58 grams snack sized bag
contains 320 calories in order to get
2,000 calories each day you would need
to eat six and a quarter bags one
positive is you wouldn't get scurvy
chips have a surprising amount of
vitamin C in fact due to the dehydration
during frying they actually have more
vitamin C per weight than a raw potato
but in some negative news a bag of chips
has zero percent of the recommended
vitamin A which can lead to eye
infections and even a loss of vision
you'd get 0% vitamin b12 which can cause
anemia and fatigue as well as memory
loss and even hallucinations you would
also get negligible amounts of calcium
and omega-3 fatty acid meaning you'd
have osteoporosis poor wound healing and
a weakening immune system what chips and
other fried potato dishes would provide
are large amounts of salt as well as
saturated and trans fats relying on such
a diet would leave you at risk of high
blood pressure stroke heart failure as
well as heart kidney and liver disease
probably the worst ingredient eating
just chips would put into your body is a
chemical known as acrylamide acrylamide
is considered a heat generated food
toxic in and is known to be a mutagen
neurotoxin and carcinogen researchers
found that eating three small bags or
even handfuls of chips every day for
seven days increases acrylamide levels
in your body by 46 percent and it's
being estimated that french fries
account for nearly a quarter of all the
acrylamide in our diets chips are also
addictive in one study mice were given a
diet of either standard Mouse food or a
diet of chips an MRI scan revealed that
chips activated parts of the brain
associated with reward and addiction
sadly the addictive nature of chips and
the associated frequent chip consumption
is linked to ink
priest risk of mortality a recent study
evaluated 4,400 patients aged 45 to 79
over eight years and found that those
who ate more fried potatoes were more
likely to die though there are no
studies that investigate an all chip
diet there is some anecdotal evidence in
May of 2012 a young man went to his
doctor complaining about flu-like
symptoms he had gone from being
relatively fit to being tired all the
time and constantly out of breath after
seeing a specialist he discovered that
he had cirrhosis of the liver which was
surprising because he didn't drink it
turned out that his condition was the
result of his diet which consisted
overwhelmingly of McDonald's french
fries this young man eventually
developed autoimmune hepatitis due to
his eating habits and passed away at the
early age of 20 so all in all chips are
a delicious occasional snack and they
should remain that way and never become
a main component of your diet thank you
guys so much for watching this video I
just want to remind you all that our new
podcast sidenote now has a YouTube
channel that you can subscribe and
listen to there so I'm gonna put a
clickable link over here and one in the
description if you want to check that
out and follow the podcast otherwise
thanks for watching make sure you're
subscribed and we will see you next week
for another science video peace